[Music]
foreign
the Press preview a first look at what
is on the front pages time then to see
what's making the headlines with
preparer and Anita boating both with us
from now until just before midnight and
welcome to both of you so to the front
pages then let us start with the daily
mail it looks into Putin's latest
missile attacks against Ukraine the
headline the day death reigned from the
sky
zielinski pleads for more help to combat
Russian terrorist attacks reached the
front of the Guardian as it looks at
Ukraine's response to those attacks
meanwhile truss faces a showdown with
Rebels predicts the eye as they
foreshadow the prime minister's cabinet
meeting tomorrow
the financial times looks at attempts by
the bank of England and the chancellor
to calm markets as borrowing costs soar
again the paper tells us
front of the Metro covers the beginning
of a court case looking into the deaths
of seven babies the express also leading
on that
asked us the Daily Mirror
while The Sun Also covers the first
moments of this court case
as does the times
and the Daily Star looks at pubs that
are offering work packages for people
struggling with the costs of working
from home
wfp now a reminder by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us so let's return them to our
guests our paper career and Anita botan
welcome to both of you let's kick off
with Ukraine shall we mix the front page
for example up the top there of the
financial times Anita a horrific day if
you like for Ukraine after what would
presumably be predictable reprisals over
the Kirch Bridge attack
absolutely and you know that that bridge
was open you know to Great Fanfare in
2018. it was a huge symbolic as well as
um logistical victory for the ukrainians
and it surprised no one but the ferocity
and severity of the retaliation from
Russia has been extraordinary we're
talking about 80 missile attacks um 11
people dead over 60 injured and not sort
of the targets that you might expect you
know infrastructure targets but in
civilian centers in Kiev you know this
is really
um quite an astonishing and devastating
moment for the ukrainians but I mean I
almost want to take this moment to go
back to where we were in February when
this when this all began and you know it
almost felt like it was going to be some
sort of Guerrilla War and what we've
seen from the ukrainians is organization
is ruthlessness is efficiency and is
these kinds of Victories that means that
inevitably as it's been reported on many
many of the front pages they're asking
for more anti- defense systems they
really want to continue to make progress
and you know whisper it but you can see
a world in which um the ukrainians do
not have to
um you know reach negotiate assessment
with Russia and G7 leaders we know on
Tuesday will hold a virtual meeting uh
Liz truss we are told um is expected to
also call for a full meeting of NATO
leaders
urging leaders to remain steadfast and
uh President zielinski also attending
that meeting and he is the guardian
tells us you know desperately Keen to
get anti-aircraft systems in place so
this is the extra call to help as the
British combat Russian terrorist attacks
this word terrorism now being abandoned
about
yes and as well as this G7 virtual
meeting which he's intending there's
also going to be a session of the United
Nations General Assembly
um which is probably happening actually
started as we speak uh New York being a
few hours a few hours behind us and that
is due to debate Russia's land grab in
the East so it's another opportunity in
east of Ukraine it's another opportunity
for this to be discussed but zielinsky
as you write Luciano is very um is very
keen on uh asking for more anti-aircraft
um systems he spoke to Joe Biden today
about that and the Americans have two
systems which are being sent to Ukraine
but they'll say Obviously a few weeks to
get there and if you want to understand
why that why they're needed I mean today
was a perfect example it's sort of like
a different phase now and this sort of
retaliation attack for the bridge the
different phase of the of the conflict
with President Putin suggesting that uh
the targets were all military energy and
Communications assets but but the images
that we've seen on our screens all day
quite clearly showing us that that's not
the case there is um children's
playground in a park was destroyed the
German consulate and Kiev was bombed and
a civilian Bridge uh which was regularly
used by families walking over it uh busy
at Russia uh was also was also attacked
so these are quite clearly civilian
attacks which is why uh Kiev once um
once the West wants the once the rest of
the Eaters of Nito and G7 Nations to to
um to formally declare that Russia has
uh has uh embarked on terrorist acts
Estonia I think is currently changing
its legislation to uh to uh Mark exactly
that point but
um all of these attacks today were
obviously uh by virtue of missiles which
have been fired the it was about 80 I
gather right across from not Justin Kiev
but also live in the west of the country
and anipra in the center
um and the the single best way that that
Ukraine has depend itself against these
taxes with these it is with um anti-air
um defense the defense capabilities
which they don't have enough of yet so
um I think they'll be expect president
zielinski asking for more of that sort
of support tomorrow
um and he will be expecting western
western Nations which have obviously
contributed militarily quite
significantly so far uh Britain's
already said it's going to do at least
two billion pounds worth more of
military equipment next year in military
supplies
um that specifically he'll be asking for
those those sorts of systems in order to
help defend civilians in Ukraine yes and
uh you're right the U.N General Assembly
has already begun debating on whether to
demand that Russia reverse course on
annexing those four regions of Ukraine
um The Daily Express that's just uh look
at that has an interview by the look of
it with the front secretary James
cleverley who told the express we will
see this through to the end
um he had held a call with his Ukrainian
counterpart Dimitri calaiba and Liz
Trussell said the appalling attacks on
civilian areas in Kiev and elsewhere are
a clear sign of Putin's desperation the
dramatic front page or middle Pages
there rather in the express but let's
move on to Liz trust shall we um Anita
the I trust faces a showdown with Rebels
um you know back into cabinet and more
tomorrow and Wednesday
um facing what exactly do you think
I sort of suspect this might be
um less dramatic than the eyes front
page
um uh suggests because it's going to be
pretty much you know getting back to
usual so meeting the 1922 back bench
committee meeting cabinet and this is
what you would expect after um
conference and getting back into the
swing of things but there is no denying
that these are challenging times for the
Prime Minister we've had you know the
huge
um uh turmoil I would say in in the
markets and following the mini budget
and you know the the reversal over the
45p tax during Party Conference
um and I think her speech was broadly
commended and broadly very much welcomed
particularly in the hall and there was
significant support there but this
Denver less remains a very challenging
moment and where she needs to ensure
that um the party is Foursquare behind
her in order to see her through the next
few months
well the the eye is indeed dramatic
um suggesting that she will hold crunch
meetings with groups of back benches to
try to dampen the next wave of rebellion
uh Michael Gove tells the eye he's
determined to continue to speak out
um I think tank warns quatting he'll
have to cut departmental budgets by 15
if he wants to balance the books this
presumably is the ifs The Institute of
fiscal studies expecting their
assessment overnight even though the
obr's assessment pepper has been brought
forward as the Ft tells us borrowing
costs have soared again I mean it's not
that pretty for the chancellor or the PM
is it
is not and I think what's worth
remembering is that while last week we
were all sort of caught the conservative
party was um you know convulsions of
febrile infighting and um it was quite
astonishing some of the sort of you know
public statements that that cabinet
members members were making uh over
various policy positions a real
breakdown of discipline right at the top
of the party everybody was sort of
saying well you know this is all in one
place wall in Birmingham and the minute
we could get back to Westminster thing
is going to calm down well you know what
that's not going to happen because there
was actually only really a handful
dozens of Tory MPS in Birmingham last
week and they're all at Westminster and
let's not forget the Liz truss uh didn't
win the sort of majority of support
amongst conservative MPS in the last
round of their voting she only receives
a few less than a third actually of
support of MP supported her and she has
further antagonized them not just with
some of these u-turns and this sort of
policy
um really quite radical policy um
decisions despite the fact that many of
them feel that she doesn't have the
Mandate for it but also by virtue of
that that reshuffle which she packed her
cabinet and and so the senior ranks of
her government with with um with allies
therefore you know further angering some
of those MPS that were already feeling
pretty fed up so you know this is gonna
be their first opportunity it's just her
second cabinet let's not forget because
we've obviously this conference recess
via second cabinet when she meets her
MPS tomorrow her cabinet tomorrow and
then on Wednesday it's a 1922 committee
and we've heard a lot over the weekend
about how she's going to be going out
and sort of meeting MPS in the tea rooms
and trying to convince them meet them in
small groups try and win them over to to
a policy and I think you know that their
policies and I think that's that is
really all she can do at this point is
try and get those MPS on board because
they're really not in a happy place as
Westminster returns tomorrow and there's
a lot of announcements coming up with
supply side reforms in the coming weeks
before even that that's what was we
described as a medium-term fiscal event
um fiscal plan the there's a lot of lots
of possibilities for things to go very
wrong politically for her before we even
reach that point
um and you know it's really quite I
think quite a dangerous moment for her
yes and just just quickly Anita can they
continue with that reforming agenda you
know this this sort of so-called supply
side reform that they want
um and the backdrop of this as the Ft
puts it is that Tori's some tourists
believe quasi-quartang will struggle to
come up with any plausible medium-term
debt reduction plan by the end of the
month and actually you know austerity is
going to be the watchword in the future
I think it's a top ask but I do think
that Charles made a compelling argument
for growth and I think it's very clear
that the country needs needs growth and
there is a lot of support for it from
actually all sides of the aisle and so I
think that there is some momentum behind
her reforming agenda
um I think the question is like the big
challenge he's got is to bring people
with her when she does this I would just
say that there's this notion that her
cabinet is completely stuffed with um
her allies but actually several people
that ran strong campaigns against his
trust are in her cabinet um you know
Nadine zahari and Marie trevally was a
big backer of um of Tom tugenhard you've
got
um the likes of uh Suella Brahman and
Kevin badernock and I think there are
alternative voices
um in in her cabinet and I also think
that bringing in Greg hands you know
very reliable really trusted and very
capable minister to replace Connor Burns
was another good step so I think she's
only 35 days in there's a lot of Road
left to run and I think the Israel her
to be able to you know to manage a
parliamentary party in such a way that
she can get some of these ambitious
reforms through okay we will be watching
carefully won't we this week I think uh
lots more still to come including why
the government could make it easier for
Builders by relaxing the requirement to
make affordable homes back with that in
just a moment
[Music]
we'll work about you watching the Press
preview with me once again the political
editor of the guardian papakura and the
broadcaster and former conservative
special advisor Anita botan welcome back
to both of you um people let's go to the
times shall we um we talked about some
of the reforms that are coming
um but ministers uh the paper tells us
have drawn up plans to exempt developers
from having to build affordable homes to
scrap Environmental Protections and to
allow people to add extensions without
permission now how will this go down
well this is the latest in a long line
of supply side reform forms which the
government is planning it's all about
deregulation to boost growth and this I
don't think will be any less
controversial than some of the other
proposals we've seen
um I mean not least because planning I
think is going to be one of the most
difficult areas for them to get through
Parliament or the legislation required
and uh despite Liz truss's criticism of
the the anti-growth Coalition I think
you'd have to think anybody who sort of
sees uh how these things pan out in
Westminster uh would recognize that some
of her story about benches would have to
be counted amongst that undergrowth
Coalition because they're very they tend
to be extremely reticent to allow any
sort of major planning reform we've seen
uh big rebellions on it in the past year
uh you know media plans that Boris
Johnson was planning had to had to be
dropped and I suspect that these won't
be any different not least because
there's some quite controversial
elements to it according to the times
there's a one suggestion that Threshold
at which affordable homes will be be
should be built would go from
developments with 10 houses up to those
with 40 or 50 houses which of course
means a substantial decrease in the
number of affordable homes which which
could end up being built the idea being
of course that it would help boost
medium and small size developers but I'm
not sure that people trying to get on
the housing ladder particularly given
the sort of the Tory emphasis on on home
ownership we were particularly happy
about that and then another sort of
particularly controversial one would be
Michael Gove when he was
um in the in Simon Clark's job
previously as leveling up as leveling up
secretary was bringing in a Manifesto
commitment which was to ban no fault
evictions so when landlords decide for
whatever reason maybe they want to put
up the rent or
um you know any other reason that they
want to get rid of particular tenants
they don't have to give them any reason
they can just kick them out
I get sorry to interrupt you just want
to squeeze another quick one in 40
seconds if you don't mind on Scotland
and the prospective referendum on
October the 19th barring a court case
there Anita
yes this is a Supreme Court case that's
been rumbling for a little while about
um whether or not Scotland can hold a
referendum with itself without needing
permission from Westminster so quite a
big moment for sturgeon obviously she
had at the conference today restating
her commitment and her belief that
essentially a vote for the s p is a vote
for Independence so I mean we've been
here before it's tough words
um but this Supreme Court case which
they are expected not to win I mean I
hate to make predictions about these
kinds of things could be a kind of um
big moment for Scotland
Anita Boateng peppercareer thank you
both very much indeed thank you